hi everyone hear me all right yeah
sounds like it
so thank you very much for coming to my
talk thank you for spending the next
hour with me my name's Adam and I come
from the UK originally I lived in
Switzerland for last 20 years and I work
for a company called particular software
where the makers have a product called
end service Buster's anyone here heard
of an service bus
oh that's most of you that's that's good
to hear now it's great to be back in
Oslo I always love coming back here to
this lovely expensive city I've been
saving up for this trip all year and
when I get home I'll start saving for
next year I'm gonna talk about this is
not a talk about in service bus but I am
going to be showing some examples and
then service bus I'm going to be talking
about an approach and the methodology to
a certain class of problems and service
bus happens to make it really easy to
implement some of those methodologies so
I'll be using it for examples now I'm
gonna be talking about a class of
problems which not many people talk
about explicitly and actually don't
often explicitly think about when
they're writing their code to do with a
runtime behavior of that code now you
might think that's a strange thing to
say because you you do think about the
runtime behavior with your code when
you're writing it I hope you do but
there's a certain class of problems
which really only manifest themselves
when you're in production and
specifically when we think about the
arrow of time when we think about the
dimension of time in our code
historically we haven't had a really
good set of tools and approaches to this
and especially when we get into things
about around concurrency in time as well
now a little bit of background I'm gonna
talk about multi-user systems so you can
imagine that in this picture there's
people are using system and they're
touching the same piece of data at the
same time this is actually the UBS
trading floor in Stanford in Connecticut
in the US I actually worked on this
trading floor for a couple of weeks it's
not a very good place to write software
it's very very noisy but it was a lot of
fun but let's look at a more so familiar
domain and think about online retail so
this is Amazon I don't think you
actually
have Amazon in doorway right there's no
Amazon no I don't think that it is we
don't have it in Switzerland either but
I still use a German site sometimes in
the UK site because they ship to
Switzerland anyway now there's a lot of
competition in this space if you're
trying to become an online retailer you
know first of all you're competing with
the giant with Amazon and you're
competing with a whole lot of others and
you can imagine that the business come
up with kind of requirements which try
and differentiate you a bit so think
about something really simple like when
a customer orders something I want you
to look back through the history of
their orders and if they've spent $100
or more this week I want you to give him
a discount of 10% so you think okay
right I'm gonna do this we can do this
I'm gonna use DDD I'm gonna use TDD I'm
gonna use all the various things I've
learnt about I'm gonna do this property
I'm gonna tick all the boxes I'm gonna
use all the methods that I know about
just like I try to use all the different
animations and PowerPoint for this slide
and eventually you might come up with
some code which looks a little bit like
this and you can see that this is
basically doing exactly what the cust
what the business user asked for we're
looking back when this order is
submitted we're looking back through the
history we're matching the customer ID
we're looking at all the orders which
were delivered in there which was sent
in the last week and if it's greater
than a hundred we give a discount of ten
if it's less we give a discount of zero
so what's wrong with this code why is
this Co so bad you're all aunt abruption
and things are fine and you've TDD des
in dddd and you've ticked all the DS and
all the rest of it the thing is that
first of all you might get some problems
with database load right so we're doing
a lookup across a history of orders here
and we're gonna sum things up and even
if you get all that sorted so you might
have a good DB II's and you put indexes
on their tables and you optimize and do
some other work you get it all working
fast enough there's another fundamental
problem here what does it mean to be a
customer we've got this thing up here
called customer ID does that mean a
physical person right so is a customer
ID a physical person and a machine
sending orders into your website or is
it something more than that could it be
something more than that
think about a call
account so some companies do that they
say well if you're going to order stuff
on this website please use a corporate
account could have negotiated this deal
where we get discounts so a single
customer ID could be two physical people
at two computers and they could be
clicking this button more or less at the
same time so what you've got then
effectively is two threads right you've
got two threads of execution processing
orders let's assume for a moment that
our order total is ninety right so it's
below our hump our threshold of 100 and
each of these towards this two orders is
for ten now one of these ought to get
discounted right the first one that gets
processed should that get not discounted
that should take the total to a hundred
the second one should get discounted the
problem is they're executing in parallel
and they both look at a database and
they both see a sum of 90 so what
they're going to do they're both going
to send out the order with zero discount
because they're both saying it's not
above a hundred now that's problematic
because the person that comes around to
paying the bill at the end of the month
is going to have a look and say hang on
a minute
we sent in eleven orders that week and
they all got charged a full price you
told us you can do it gives a discount
right one of those should be didn't
should have been discounted at 10
percent you know you you you're not you
know that's actually breach a contract
so you say oh well you know we're
terribly sorry we'll give you a discount
or a free refund or something and then
you think well we must have a bug in the
system that must must must be something
wrong so then you look at it and you
realize that well they pretty much press
the button at the same time or within a
couple of seconds of each other so you
get back to the customer say that I'm
terribly sorry but you order too quickly
in order to quickly well if you just
waited a few seconds before the second
order we were they giving you a discount
kind of look at you funny and say what
you know how do you expect me to do that
we have 10 people using this website now
how do I coordinate that and then you
say why don't those shout around the
office or something and then at that
point they're Sarah I thank for you to
business you know I'm going to Amazon
instead every owner at the the term
death by Amazon all right that's what
Amazon does if you don't run your
business efficiently enough Amazon will
eat you so that's not good enough
now you think well we've got the problem
we've got to solve this problem on
outside somehow sunny you think well
what about transactions why don't we
just wrap each of these things in the
transaction that'll sort out right the
problem is that most of the most major
database platforms are sequel server
oracle etc use an isolation level for
transactions by default which is called
at least in sequel server reads
committed so what that means is the
transaction isolation level will allow
both of these threads to read this 90
write if I try and write to the same row
or something afterwards it will sense it
will actually not allow one of the
transactions to commit but it allowed
them to read this figure of 90 so that's
not really going to fix it out the Box
either but then you read about
serializable transactions and sequel
server and what that means is that each
transaction takes out read locks on all
the stuff it's read and when they try
and write back then they'll actually not
allow the transaction to commit if the
other thing hasn't released its read
lock and that'll solve the problem the
problem is you switch that on and all of
a sudden your error logs just fill up
right so you quickly panic and go oh no
your switch thing off again but the
thing is what you've got to realize is
that those errors are feedback those
error logs are telling you you've got
concurrency problems in your system
they're telling you that people are
clicking the button at the same time
it's only kind of scratching your head
you're kind of running out of ideas but
then you think well I've solved this
before I've sold this another way before
we had concurrency problems in another
system and to do that I wrote a batch
job now you might end up with code which
does something like this in some kind of
batch job instead say instead of doing
this on the fly when people are
submitting orders we're going to loop
through all the customers one by one and
look back through the history and we're
going to set their discount level to ten
or zero according to how much how much
stuff they've ordered now there is a
kind of behavior problem with that as
well but before I go into that think
about the technical side of this as well
now this is in c-sharp okay or whatever
your favorite programming language is
whatever you've written your best of
your system in now that's a good
situation if you're lucky you get
to writing in c-sharp and if you're
really lucky if you're really
disciplined you might even put it inside
this nice encapsulation you've got here
a nice ddd and micro service and SOA
developed solution which nicely
encapsulated encapsulation of database
but what often happens is this stuff
tends to live outside it comes to kind
of get bolted on the side and go
directly goes directly to the database
now if you are lucky enough to be
writing this in c-sharp or your favorite
language whatever you do don't let your
DBAs see it because when your DBA sees
it will say that should be written in
sequel and they'll and it's a bit to be
fair they might be right and they're
good at this right DBAs are good at this
right they know how to make super server
perform well then how to tune and
optimize it and I just put indexes and
tables and indeed it turns out is
running faster so they give you this
stored procedure and very often what
I've seen before is they write the
initial version of the stored procedure
and then kind of give it to you for
maintenance and because this thing is
working well and efficiently soon all
right the business come along and they
say well you know that batch jobs things
that we did a few a couple of weeks ago
to do that this counting thing yeah we
need another one of those too this other
thing and then another one appears and
then another one appears and another one
appears now what starts and this is just
random sequel by the way that I just
copied and pasted it from somewhere I
don't even know what it is but the point
it kind of all looks the same anyway
right but the the the problem here is
that the interesting stuff is actually
all going on on the outside here right
this stuff in the middle is kind of
shrinking in importance
all right all the new funky business
requirements all the all the
differentiators all those things that
are giving you competitive advantage are
starting to be coded on the outside here
this is becoming the system right it's
kind of is anyone here familiar with a
Strangler pattern anyone heard that
so Strangler pattern as a few of you the
Strang of the pattern very briefly is
when you have a nasty piece of cut piece
of code you'd gradually carve out bits
of that code with and replace it with
nice pieces of code until you strangle
the bad code out of existence there's
almost some kind of like
reverse strangle a pattern right the
nice code is being strangled out of
existence and this stuff kind of starts
to take over your life and I've been in
a situation before I've laid a bed I've
laid in bed awake at night thinking
about how to debug stored procs all of a
sudden you realize you become a sort of
stored proc specialist or something and
it's not a nice situation to be in
because ultimately you've got this kind
of big ball of mud written install
procedures and it I've been in the
situation and it's really quite
unpleasant but even taking all that
aside even if you manage to avoid that
situation even man if you manage to keep
it in c-sharp you manage to keep it in
your domain modern you keep it nice
there's another fundamental problem here
previously we were basically penalizing
users for clicking the button at the
same time or within a few seconds of
each other we are now penalizing them
for clicking on the same day because
what you're effectively saying is if
you're gonna order a load of stuff don't
or what am more than $100 worth on
Monday order $100 worth of Monday wait
till Tuesday so the overnight batch can
run and then send in the rest of the
orders and customs gonna say right
bye-bye I'm off to Amazon it's just not
gonna work that might have been good
enough in the early days of e-commerce I
don't know but these days people expect
more so we can't just take this to two
or three second race condition and
expand it to a 24 hour race condition
right this is one of the reasons that
businesses are trying to get away from
things like batch jobs so we need
another way to think about this arrow of
time with another we need another
approach another model to think about
how we're gonna program the arrow of
time so here it is here's our arrow of
time and if business is going smoothly
we're gonna be get orders flowing
through the website now the requirement
we've been given again is when an order
comes in I want you to look back through
the history of the orders sum them up
and if the week total is more than 100
give a discount right now that is not
the requirement one of the things I've
come to realize over the past few years
users and business people don't
often give you requirements what they
tend to do is give you workarounds
within the constraints of the current
system they know that we're recording
orders they know we've got this order
history of customer IDs and totals and
things and they know that if we go back
through that history and sum all those
orders up we can work out whether it's a
discount or not so they've given you
that workaround the actual requirement
is when a customer has has a spent over
$100 in a week give him a discount now
that might seem like just a subtle
change in wording but the problem is
because we've getting away from that go
back through history and look up we're
already not tied that as a solution I
can start to think about other ways of
doing things we don't necessarily have
to look back in time we can actually
kind of look forward in time now I'm not
saying we can predict the future but
there are methods where it can kind of
fold the history and the future into our
current code so let's have another look
at the arrow of time now when the first
order comes in what's the current what's
the customer's current week total it's
zero exactly right so what are we going
to give when the first order comes in
when they give no discount right that's
simple now we've introduced this concept
of a week total huh or a weekly total so
we can say well the weekly total right
now is zero but importantly we add the
current order into the weekly total okay
because this is now going to count our
weekly total but even more importantly
in one week from now we need to remove
that order total prior week total when
the second order comes in with you the
same thing again we add the order total
to the week total and importantly in one
week from that moment we need to remove
that order from the week total and you
can see as we do this for every order
that comes in we're gonna have this kind
of sliding window of the week total and
what orders are going to be added to it
at one point they're going to be taken
away exactly a week later so you can see
that's gonna kind of slide through time
and give us that weekly total and
one point in time and we do it for every
other the order that comes into the
website and when a specific order comes
in what do we do that we look back
through the history or we don't have to
do that anymore right we just look at
the week total so what we're doing here
is we're basically updating a single
number so it's consistent in the same
way that the batch job was consistent
where we're updating a single discount
level for a customer we're now updating
a single row in the database to hold
this week total and databases are really
good a guarantee and transactionality
around the single row in a database I'll
come to that a bit more in a minute but
what we've done here is instead of
fudging the number by performing
calculations over the existing domain
objects we've introduced this concept
into our domain itself I've got this
week total which has become part of our
ubiquitous language and it's a kind of
it's a kind of inverted kind of inverse
anti batch job if you like but the thing
is we need a good way to program this so
how we're gonna program this element of
time how are we gonna program this
taking away the order in a week's time
how we're gonna make sure that happens
you can't really do it with HTTP well I
don't know any way of sending an HTTP
request and having it arrive at the
consumer you know a week later doesn't
really cut it for that you can kind of
fudge it with system threading timer or
something like that but the problem is
that's fine until the process crashes
okay the process starts up again it's
forgotten because that's all in memory
so we need another approach now what I'm
going to do do now is introduce a notion
of a saga has anyone heard of the saga
pattern that's all that's probably at
least half of you okay so very briefly
saga it was a term coined in the late
80s I think it was 1987 it was
effectively about rolling back
transactions and breaking transactions
into smaller transactions so take a big
transaction it was you have you have a
series of smaller transactions if one
succeeds with another succeeds unless
exceeds another fails you kind of roll
back the previous steps and that's kind
of what the original saga pattern
described we've abstracted that a little
more generally because the thing is that
saga that the real world doesn't really
roll itself back
doesn't really undo itself in our saga
abstraction effectively all it abstracts
is a message coming in another message
coming in later and then what you do
when that second message arrives depends
on what happened in the first message
right in order to do that when the first
message arrives we've saw state when the
second message is arrived Mesut message
arrives we retrieve that state and we
make decisions based on the second
message and the state from the first
message that's basically what a saga is
and this this kind of undoing I often
see this example so when people talk
about sagas they talk about booking a
holiday so you need to book a flight new
typical hotel room and you took book a
hire car I tried to use sort of typical
images from a Norwegian family holiday
here I've got this right and when you
book your flight that succeeds we meant
to be Otel then you try and pick your
hire car and they're all sold out so
what do you do right holidays off we're
not going we're going to roll the whole
thing back when the councilor town
cancel the flight it's a really bad
example so if you see people using this
example when they talk about sagas you
know call them out on X it's a really
bad example the real word this real
world is rich than that so when we when
we fail to rent the hire car we go to
another company if they're all sold out
we look at other forms of transport
stretch limo or something so we need a
more general pattern which is not just
tied to this kind of rolling back which
is a bit unrealistic so that's a lot of
talking let me show you a little bit of
code now I'm just going to show you
generally what a saga looks like I'm not
going to do anything exciting here I
just want to kind of show you the API
just before we go back to our use case
so what we've got here is we've got a
flight booked class which we're going to
which we're going to use as a message
and that just has a holiday ID on it
we've got a hotel booked message with a
holiday ID and a card books message with
a holiday ID now our requirement is for
this saga when the flights been booked
when the hotel's been built when the
car's been booked
I want to spa Bechet holiday booked
message
and then something else in the system
can go and do something else now these
only contain IDs because I'm assuming
that other parts of the system know
about the details right so all we
actually need for this use case is just
the idea of the holiday okay so we
published this holiday book message and
then something else in the system can
then say okay I'm going to email the
customer turn their holidays being built
or I'm gonna build them for the holiday
or do whatever so a saga is as simple as
a class right that's all the saga is
it's just a class so I've called it
holiday booking and the first thing we
need to do is we needed to find some
kind of class to hold the state in
between these different message that in
between receiving these different
messages so I'm gonna use a nested class
for that and I know some people hate
nested classes but I think they're quite
nice in this specific use case because
they demonstrate that this data is for
this saga and nothing else now I'm I'm
inheriting from a base class called
contains saga data that just has some
infrastructure stuff on it like a kind
of internal ID for the saga who sent the
original message what was the original
message we don't care about that in this
use case that's useful for other things
but just to show you what that class is
so in our class we're defining the whole
holiday ID because ultimately that's the
thing we have to raise the event for at
the end we're recording the fact that
the flight is booked that the hotel is
booked and that the car is booked now
what we can do is we can Herot from a
saga based class and we tell it that the
state is going to be stored in this
nested data class that we just defined
now we need to handle the three messages
so we need to handle flight booked hotel
booked hopes her hotel booked and car
booked and what that does it gives us a
bunch of methods to implement called
handle and in each of those we get the
message itself and we get a context
object which is just a thing that we can
use to send other messages within the
method so when we receive flight book we
say is flight booked true hotel books
hotel books is true kharbut car box is
true
and in each case we call this checkbook
to method and that's down here and all
that's doing is it's saying when the
flights booked when the hotel's booked
and the cars booked we publish using
this context object that's been passed
in a holiday booked event with the
holiday ID okay now at that point we're
done right the saga has served its
purpose because that's all its purposes
it's when the three things have been
booked raised an event to say that's
been done so the rest of the system can
do something so what we can do now is we
can mark as complete and that's the
method on the base class which just says
this sagas done right it doesn't need to
exist anymore there's just one thing
left to do and that is to configure how
to find the saga in the database so all
this does it says for each of these
message types so flight hotel and car
take the holiday ID from the message and
map it to the holiday ideas a saga that
effectively tells the infrastructure how
to form a select statement in the
database so when a message comes in try
and select an existing saga if it
doesn't exist create one now I know I've
gone through that pretty quickly but
I'll show you sort of diagrammatic
explanation of what's actually happening
there so we have kind of two important
abstractions here we have the bus and
the persister the bus is kind of an
abstraction over a message queue so that
might be as a service bus or rabbitmq or
MSM queue or any other queueing system
the persister is effect is essentially
an abstraction over a database and that
could be sequel server or a call or rave
and DB or MongoDB as any matter now when
we receive the first message the bus
tries to retrieve the saga from the
database and because it's the first
message with that Holliday ID it doesn't
find it - that but that gets that goes
all the way back to the bus the bus
knows that it has to create a new saga
object it dispatches the method into it
the message into it which is basically
calling the handle method that handle
method will alter the internal state it
may or may not send messages out and at
that point we persist the saga excuse me
in the database which is basically an
insert statement if you're using sequel
server or something like that
when the second message comes in we do
the same thing again we try and retrieve
the stock from the database this time it
does find it because we saved it after
the first message it then creates a new
sagar object fills it with the data from
last time and gives it back to the bus
then we do the same thing again with
dispatch the new message into it that in
alters the internal state somehow might
send more messages out and we persist
the saga again which is basic than an
update statement or we might decide
we're done right in this case we mark
ourselves as complete and the persister
basically deletes it from the database
the saga is basically done so I hope
most of that makes sense so now that we
know kind of more or less how a saga
works if we go back to our use case how
can we use the saga for our business use
case how can we actually achieve this
and importantly how can we do this magic
do something in a week from now so again
I think the best thing is for me to show
you the code so what I've got here is a
couple of other messages so we have a
submit order message with a customer ID
and a order total so just how much the
orders for and it will have some other
stuff which I'll just left out for
brevity then we have a process order
message with a discount level okay and
whatever other properties it needs to
for something else to process the order
so the requirement here is when we
receive a submit order message work out
the discount and send the message to
process the order with at this gun right
that's that's the requirement for this
saga that's it's single responsibility
so again we've got a discounting class
I've called a discounting this time this
is gonna be our saga for the saga data
I'm going to store the customer ID
because we do discounting for cut at the
customer level for each customer and I'm
storing the week total okay I'm using a
double here you probably won't do that
in real life might use kind of money
type or something that's appropriate
accuracy but just using a double for
simplicity now what we can do is we can
say that our saga is going to
permantly is going to inherit from the
base class discounting data is going to
be our state storage and we can handle
the submit order message right so we can
say I am started by messages type
submit' order that gives us again a
handle method to implement and in here
we're doing what we're asked to do so
we're saying if the if the week total is
greater or equal to a hundred the
discount level is ten otherwise it's
zero we then send our process order
message with that discount level and
here we need to add the current order to
the week total for when the next message
comes in when the next order is
submitted and here's a really important
bit right here's the bit of magic we're
going to request a time out seven days
from now with the same message right
this is say is again this request time
it has a method on the saga base class
and what we do then is we hand we
implement this interface called I handle
timeouts of submit order so not only am
i now started by submit order I handled
timeouts of submit order and we
implement a timeout method and then that
timeout method we know that when this
method is called seven days have passed
right so all we do here is we take away
all the total from the week total right
and effectively we're done there's that
one last thing to do we need to
configure how to find the saga so we
need to say when a submit order message
comes in map the customer ID of the
message the customer ID of the saga so
we can correlate alright and now we're
basically done now this code is pretty
easy to read right all we're doing a
series saying well what's the discount
level send the process order message
adds the total right a week later take
it away from the total it's exactly what
I showed you in the diagram so how does
this actually work what does what does
the infrastructure actually do when this
happens so again when we get the first
message in we retrieve a saga I've left
that bit out because you've already seen
it but once we've got the saga object we
dispatch the method into the mess
into it by calling the method the handle
method the saga does some internal state
manipulation and then it requests a
timeout right that's a method you've
just seen at this point the bus does one
of two things either it puts the message
directly in the message coud and says
deliver me this message in a week and
some queueing system support that so I
think the only one does it fully out of
the box is either service bus which
despite its name is just a queueing
system but it does support that
out-of-the-box rabbitmq and amazon sqs
kind of do it I'll come to that in a
minute and other two other queueing
systems don't do it at all so MSM queue
has no facility for this so in those
cases we actually persist the timeout in
the database at the same time as we
persists our data and then we pull the
database to see when the timeouts become
due
that's not ideal we don't really want to
be pulling the database if we can avoid
it so we always prefer allowing the
queue itself to do the work over here
now I'm gonna take a quick dive under
the covers and sort of peek behind the
curtain and I'll show you what any
service bus does behind the scenes a
little bit here because it's quite
interesting in the context of Amazon sqs
I've said that it kind of supports this
and it does because it only allows you
to to delay a message by 900 seconds so
15 minutes is the maximum so if you want
to delay a message by 600 seconds that's
fine you just tell Amazon sqs to say to
deliver this message in 600 seconds if
you want to do something like 2,800
seconds it's a bit more complicated we
can only put this message in the queue
for 900 seconds right that's the limit
but what we can also do is we can write
a custom header on the message like a
message for ourselves to say when we
receive this back there still a delay of
1900 remaining so we know we can put it
back on the queue for another 900 and
when we get that back we know there's a
thousand remaining by looking at that
header put that in the queue for another
900 seconds so we know there's only 100
remaining and we just put it in this
queue for a hundred seconds so using
that by flowing the message through
these queues four times we can actually
simulate a delay of 2,800 seconds right
I'm good either arbitrarily for any kind
of delay that works pretty well
I bet MQ is a bit more interesting
rabbitmq has a Singh called time to live
and what that means is for a specific
queue in the rabbit MQ you can say
messages live in this queue for this
amount of time so what we do is we say
we send the message into that queue
let's say at 600 seconds we've set the
600 a second time to live we put a
message in that queue we don't we don't
subscribe to that queue at all but what
we do is we tell rabbits that when when
a message falls out of this queue when
it when it's exceeded it's time to live
put it in this other queue right and we
subscribe to that queue instead so using
that we can actually simulate delayed
delivery and naba MQ right and that
works pretty well because then you can
create a queue with 900 second time to
live one with 1500 seconds one with 2800
seconds but you might be starting to
spot the problem here you're gonna have
to have a separate queue for every delay
level you want in your system now the
API looks like this right and I can
write any number I like in there okay if
I want to be really evil I can write
random dot next right and I don't think
any there might be some business where
there might be use case flow I don't I
might want to randomize their delays for
some reason but the problem is that at
the number of queues could kind of grow
and kind of grow infinitely right we
don't want customers asking us why and
service buses Krang 50,000 queues in
their rabbit MQ broker so we need
another approach now let's take a more
simple example 42 seconds right we all
love that number but it's only written
with the digits 4 and 2 in base 10 right
so this is 42 in base 10 or decimal but
us clever computer program programmers
we know there are other counting systems
like binary and we can write this as one
hundred and one thousand and ten seconds
in base two or binary now what if we
create a queue with a 32 second time to
live one with 16 second time to live one
with eight on the four two and one we
can take on number 42 and write it in
binary alongside these queues we can
send this message through the 32 second
queue skip the sixteen through the eight
skip the four through the set through
the two skip the one and by sending the
message through the 32 plus the 8 plus
or two which is 42 we've simulated a 42
second delay and rabbitmq right and now
though I don't I haven't seen anyone
else do that in the in the community I
think it's quite a kind of original
invention so you know I think it's we
can we can we can simulate a delay of up
to 63 seconds right with these with
these six cues which isn't a lot so we
actually create 28 cues which means you
can have a maximum delay of two to the
28 seconds or this big number here or
about eight and a half years now you
might think well why eight and a half
years it's bit why 28 cues is a bit
arbitrary well we consider 25 which
would give you just over a year but then
we didn't like backs it was odd so we
thought 26 and then we thought well 26
we think that's safe but let's just go
one order of magnitude higher just to be
safe so 27 was a candidate but of course
that was odd so it ended up being 28
we're really tempted to go for 32 but
that would have given us a maximum that
I have 136 years and it's nice to think
that someone's using an service bus 136
years from now but it's probably bit
over the top so 28 years if someone
really needs more than 8 and a half
years we'll add at 20 nights whatever I
would probably add a 30 at the same time
so have we solved our problem here right
we've got this nice sauger now it's only
touching one row but thing is the users
don't care don't care we're using a song
they're still going to start pressing
the button at the same time so we're
still going to get two of these saga
things executing concurrently you know
maybe on different processes or maybe if
you're using two threads in your process
and they're still gonna see the saga
state of 90 right they're both gonna see
in 90 and this weekly total so we
haven't actually solved a problem at all
right but the thing is remember that
we're writing the saga state to a single
row in the database now now we can
actually take advantage of regular
optimistic concurrency so we've seen how
these things get invoked we've seen that
this this this same process is going to
happen in two different threads now
what's going to happen here is that the
sagas are going to
c19 the database they're gonna set the
discount of zero they're gonna send the
process order message with a discount of
zero which is wrong both of them are
going to do that but because they're
trying to write the saga state to the
same row in the database one of them is
going to succeed right and importantly
it's messages will be sent because n
service bus guarantees that the messages
are only sent from the handle method if
the saga state is persisted all right so
that line of code which says context got
published a context dot send we don't
actually send the message at that point
we send the message as we save the saga
as we save the saga state so those
message those messages get sent this
transaction gets refused because it's
trying to write to the same row so these
messages are not sent at that point that
message gets rolled back to the queue it
gets invoked into the saga instance
again now the saga is going to read the
updated state from that other thread
right it will now be a hundred so it
will give a discount of 10% and
importantly it will be able to save its
targeted saga state the messages will go
out and we have achieved our objective
okay so you know we're getting on the
way to killing the batch job and I'll
tell you what a particular software this
is one of our missions right we want to
kill the batch job we want to rid the
world of that jobs we even published a
blog post a couple years ago called
deaths of the batch job I was just on
that on our website and one of the
reasons for that is because when you
start to use this alternate programming
model this becomes part of your domain
right this saga lives in the little
lives in the rest of your code it lives
it uses you what the main objects it's
all nicely DD deed and TD deed and it's
not this kind of separate thing on the
outside now the problem is that we speak
to people about this and no matter how
hard we try well you always get to the
point where the customers still talk
about they still say well ok that's all
really well and good but in this
specific case I still really need batch
jobs I still really need them that
something else this isn't gonna work for
me one of the really common
the things is reports so anyone here
work with a system which produces
reports it's quite a common thing yeah
that's about half of you so I worked
with a system in my previous job and the
overnight batch job started to finish
around lunchtime right we actually
became victims our own success that
business was going well and this thing
because we're getting more and more
things in database you know more
customers ordering things the batch job
was growing and growing and growing to
the point where I mean I don't know
where it is now and I left a couple of
years ago but you know is we was
threatening to start finishing towards
the end of the working day which really
isn't very practical at all you know
getting close to when you actually have
to kick off the next one that night and
then of course if you open an office in
Singapore or in New York or in San
Francisco you actually don't have any
night anymore so you know the whole
concept of well I mean like bash up kind
of falls away but the thing about
reports is that if you look at what the
users are doing with reports if you
start to ask why right and this is a
really important thing you need to start
asking why there's this thing called
five why's where you kind of go through
this process of asking why kind of
around five times until you get to the
actual requirement and they tell you
that they run this report at some time
in the morning every day and let's say
this is some kind of banking domain or
something there looks at a report and
they and they say well I look for large
transactions in high-risk countries and
if there's three of those within a week
then I kick off some kind of process I
go and talk to my manager or I call the
customer or I temporarily lock the
account or do something now you're
already starting to learn things by
asking those questions you've learned
that there is a concept of a large
transaction and there's a concept of a
high-risk country I risk country and
then once a year large transactions over
ten thousand dollars are high-risk
countries any one of these six something
like that so your again your bit your
ubiquitous language and Dedede terms is
starting to get enriched now the thing
is again the report was never a
requirement my it was status as a
requirement but it is actually a
workaround
within the constraints of the current
system they knew that these transactions
are being held they knew that if they
put them into a report each day they
could look through them find the highest
transactions the possible fraudulent
transactions and take some action the
actual requirement was when there are
three possible fraudulent transactions
within a week I want to know about it so
why not use something like a saga and do
some kind of automated pattern matching
so we can subscribe to events we can say
let's say there's a transaction occurred
event or something like that we can look
at those events we can examine them we
can say it's this a large is this a
large transaction you know is it over
$10,000 is it a high-risk country yes
it's in one of these six if so we add
that transaction to our saga state to
say possible fraud in transaction while
you put it into a collection in our saga
state then we send the message to
ourselves one week from now to remove
that transaction from our possible fraud
in transactions and again what we've
built for ourselves is the same
sliding-window right we've got a sliding
window of one week which is recording
all the possible fraudulent transactions
within that week and we know that any
time when that collection count hits
three we need to inform the user so we
might send them an email or something
and they might then go and tell their
manager and the thing is that this might
happen that's a half past four in the
afternoon right and you usually check
that report at 9:30 in the morning so
the manager says to you well hang on
it's half past four in the afternoon you
normally check that report at 9:30 why
is it taking you seven hours to tell me
right you should be telling in this
straightaway you know this is urgent we
need to do something they say oh no
system told me what do you mean the
system told you oh yeah you know that
saga thing the developers are talking
about a couple of weeks ago yeah they
they implemented that they rolled it all
out and then a system just tells me they
say well what you mean you don't you
don't look at that report anymore sir I
haven't looked at the report for two
weeks right the system now tells us and
we know exactly when it
we can take action straight away we
don't have to wait to the next day and
this is kind of mind-blowing
right this is when managers hear this
kind of thing this is like real time
business intelligence all right this is
where they say well I want more of that
stuff yeah that saga stuff I want more
of that okay well how do i how do i how
do I get more of that where do I sign
because ultimately this translates to
actual business value right this is
actual money i these are these are
Norwegian kroner right is it is that the
right money I actually don't really see
this very often nowadays do you it's
kind of all plastic but this does
translate into actual business value
right so this is actual money this is
when a software development team can
start to transition from being a cost
center to being a profit Center so
before I wrap up I've shown you a little
bit about an service bus here if you
want to know a little bit more about
that we've got this game going on it's
it's this kind of space exploration game
where it kind of takes you through the
API and shows you that so you can follow
that URL and see that their details
about that down in our booths on the
exhibition hall as well and I hope that
this has given you a kind of different
perspective on this arrow of time
there's a couple of key takeaways that
we take with you so the first thing is
that you want to be using a programming
model which embraces the aspect of time
okay you don't want to be fudging this
by doing historical lookups or batch
jobs and that kind of thing you want a
programming model which embraces the
aspects of time and actually allows you
to put that into your code right using
something like durable messaging allows
you to do that and they're in a reliable
and and to guarantee that's going to
happen rather than trying to fudge that
with some kind of database polling of
your own because then you end up you end
up just building your own cue anyway so
we'll use some kind of programming model
which actually embraces this aspect and
you can then fold it into your DDD
aggregate roots so sagas has anyone read
Eric Evans Dedede book that's a few of
you so in there he talks about aggregate
roots sagas are actually very good
accurate aggregate roots so if you think
about it what they do is they
encapsulate private data
and moreover they're actually just very
good objects so if you've ever read
anything by Alan Kay who wrote about
object orientation a long time ago he
never really talked about polymorphism
and inheritance and that kind of thing
he talked about objects receiving
messages encapsulating data and business
logic and sending other messages out
right sounds very much like a saga so I
often say that sagas are a just object
orientation done right with a difference
that they are persisted right they
survive process restarts so it's like a
persistent state object that's alive
process restarts and it wraps up this
kind of messages in a messages out thing
for you
there are very very good test targets so
any fans of any fans of TDD here so half
I bet the people who didn't put their
hands up absolutely hate it it's a kind
of love-hate thing with TDD I think part
of the problem there is that we've never
had really good units to TDD so because
and because a saga completely
encapsulates its data and it's just
messages coming in messages going out
it's a very very good TDD target you can
kind of get around the whiteboard with
your domain experts and say well you
know when this happens and this happens
and this happens when we get these
messages in we want these messages out
and we have a testing package friend
service bus which allows you to put a
testable context into those methods that
context object and you can call a few
handle methods and then look at the
context objects to see which messages
messages were sent out so they're very
very good TDD targets and I do recommend
that you do that right I do recommend
that you test sagas especially if you're
looking at the aspect of time because
you you don't want to be kind of sending
something into the system waiting a week
and then waiting to see if it happens
correctly you can actually just call the
request timeout method and do that and
do that in your code the other thing
that I really wanted to take away again
is that thing about workarounds versus
requirements okay and that's that this
involves talking to your business which
is often a tough thing to do but I
actually do think it's one of the
biggest challenges that we have as
developers is to actually get to the
real requirements
because I think more often lot in my
career I've been given workarounds
within the within the constraints of the
current system and it's it's part of
that asking why and actually getting
back to the actual requirement itself
that's a bit of an art form and
ultimately it's okay it can be an
organizational problem sometimes it can
be difficult just to talk to the people
that have that information you know
sometimes you might have a business
analyst sitting between you and the
actual business users or kind of proxy
domain expert kind of person so actually
getting in the same room with the actual
people that can give you the real
quirements is sometimes a challenge as
well and that's just an example of kind
of an organizational problem which is
ultimately a lot of problem that we face
as developers now we don't face as many
technical problems as we think it's
actually a lot of organizational problem
where things come from so I hope that's
given you a good sort of different quite
a different method and different
methodology of thinking about this era
of time and they're taking kind of
toolkit in your a different thing in
your toolkit to actually think about how
to actually get that into your systems
and how to model it so I've actually
raced through that content I think I've
got over ten minutes left so if anyone's
got any questions right now I'll be more
than happy to take them yeah do I have
experience with overusing sagas the
answer to that is an unqualified yes
because what I've seen sometimes is once
you learn about sagas you start seeing
sagas everywhere right and so they're
not that like anything they're not that
golden hammer they're not that Silver
Bullet which would solve all your
problems they are something to be chosen
to be used and yes I've seen people
overuse them definitely yeah I mean one
of the things is that one of the
specific examples is that people
sometimes think that a saga is an
Orchestrator for a much wider business
process so say well we've got a service
over here and a service over here and a
service over here let's say it's flights
and hotels and booking and the saga
needs to orchestrate all of that the
problem is that when you so I give
another talk called finding your service
boundaries and that's also online I gave
it
last year in there I talked about how to
actually find their service boundaries
and how you must not cross service
boundaries within us within a saga or
anything else so it's important to say
that a saga is within a service boundary
or a bounded context if you like in son
of DDD terms use a saga within a bounded
context if something else needs to
happen some other bounded context
raising the vent from that saga start a
new saga new bounded context so don't
have this kind of God saga encompassing
everything still respect your bounded
context in your service boundaries by
splitting those splitting a larger
workflow up into smaller sagas is that
more or less answer the question
hey any more questions yeah
so is it sorry but is a bit difficult to
hear you but you're saying when you have
a service layer yeah right
right so when he ever alright so when
you have a service layer we've got this
with this delayed messages thing and I'm
trying to use it for part of the
business logic and you're saying that
you're saying it's dangerous okay so is
it dangerous is your question is it
dangerous okay so you're saying right so
you're saying I'm scattering the logic
well yes yes I am I'm spreading the
logic over time but what I'm doing there
is I'm actually embracing the business
requirement so that is actually the
business requirement is that we want to
keep we want to keep a window of the
current week total for a customer and we
want to take action based on that right
so what I'm actually doing is I'm
actually embracing that business logic
in my code and I can see I can see that
you know I can read that code and say
well I see what happens now I see what
happens in a week's time
so you know that actually expresses that
requirement
so I can see maybe you're nervous about
the fact that this stuff is in timeouts
any kind of and it's kind of hidden from
view right so what you can do then is
you can kind of use a CQ RSS kind of
approach to say well you can raise an
event and and written and write that out
into a read model so that any one time
you can say well I've got these things
which are pending right I've got these
uncompleted sagas effectively and
actually that is one of the other
pitfalls of using sagas is we often have
a lot of customers who ask how do I see
what's inside the saga you know how do I
see inside the saga data and the problem
with that is you don't want to be doing
that because then you're punching
through the abstraction and all of a
sudden you can't actually change your
saga in isolation because you've got all
these other things looking into the
database so that's why it's really good
to raise events and actually capture
that as a first-class read model to say
well you know this is the state of this
process right now and I'm going to write
that onto an explicit read model does
that lay some of your fears around the
kind of
yeah
so so Azure storage cues is another
transport is another cue that we do
support that does not have any kind of
delayed delayed message mechanism
built-in so we do use the database
method for as a service bus either
service bus as a different queueing
technology that has the native delays
built-in I'm finding a little bit
difficult to hear you now so come and
come and grab me afterwards and welcome
to the conversation okay any other
questions before we wrap up yeah
mm-hm
right okay okay so your question is you
you do this transactional thing at the
beginning you do a similar transactional
thing at the end when the message
becomes due in a week's time and do you
have the same transactional guarantees
around it so the answer is yes because
when you receive it when you receive
that time out in a week's time you can
do that it's it's exactly like a regular
message handling so you handle the
message the the sagas internal state
will get mutated somehow you'll persist
that state and actually you're
persistent regardless even if it's not
mutated and again if you're sending
messages out from that time out method
if you can't persist the state because
there's another concurrent operation
that transaction will get rolled back
and the message won't go out so handling
the time out has exactly the same
transactional guarantees around it as
handling the initial message
okay so I'll let you go about a few
minutes early I've hope you enjoyed that
I hope you enjoyed the rest of the
conference
I am I am gonna be at the particular
software booth for most of the rest of
today and probably tomorrow so we've got
more questions please do come and grab
me and more than more than interested to
answer them for you I hope you enjoy the
rest of the conference I've enjoyed
talking to you and thank you very much
[Applause]